you talk about the job being [ __ ] right
this was what people would say at the
time yeah I don't think this certainly
in living memory there's been a time
where it seems like crime and the
streets of London knife crime gun crime
the things that you talked about is
worse than it is now it seems like it's
terrible doesn't it we hear about people
being stabbed as you were shot all the
time I mean it's a daily occurrence now
what is going on in the streets of our
cities we've lost control we used to
have control of the streets when I was
in the job and I've been retired ten
years now we actually went out in
numbers we had the numbers we had the
squads and if a job come in for example
where I remember taking her Crime
Stoppers call and I think I knew who the
informant was but it come through
anonymously and this guy had attacked
his own mother father I think it was or
yeah and punched her in the face
not about 90 thell it was a dangerous
dangerous man and I recalled taking
there and I turn around and I said to
the day I write this guy I know where he
is
I've got an address we need to Nick him
he said right I want two teams out who
wants to come in tomorrow morning six
o'clock
any rest day workings which you know
were always great always added up to the
CID paid he'll buy a pint or two when we
celebrated getting a good job down or
also when we commiserate when we lost a
job which we knew we should have won but
the point was we had two teams together
we all went home that night went a bed
four o'clock in the morning we were all
up two cars got the equipment we needed
had the right people we needed we didn't
[ __ ] about in those days nowadays you've
got pretty soft police service some
pretty tough ones in those days you know
we weren't frightened of challenging
anyone we knew we had the big boys with
firearms if we needed them we knew that
we had the clout and the numbers to go
around and we did not [ __ ] about we
actually did the job didn't beat him up
occasionally there was a very violent
arrest
but we had to use the violence in
response to the violence that was often
portrayed to us anyway on that
particular occasion I remember our
actually had one of the signed Idol
battles on trial because I was the lead
campaigner for him so I took that one
with me and I remember the neck the
following morning we put the door in
other guys weren't rounded back because
we make sure they don't escape from
windows and doors and I realized that
you know you if you can even beat your
own mother up and she would very
seriously G be aged but the point was we
had the numbers to do the job with the
will to do the job and we wanted to do
it the sad reality today is over the
last 10 years we've lost almost 22,000
frontline police officers Theresa May
had a bit of a dream job at the Home
Office nobody really challenged her and
what she decided to do because of
austerity is to cut policing but she cut
policing at a time when the mood and the
change on the streets of Britain had
reached a stage where guns and knives
were being used but will people would
get involved in an argument in a pub for
argument say or in a part in a high
street in a club and within minutes they
have a gun and we had we had to deal
with that and more people was carrying
knives more people were carrying guns
and we we need to be able to deal with
that so what Theresa May did is she
started reducing the police service and
there's a chap called Sir Tom Windsor
and he was her hatchet man and he was
just before I retired from the police
service he came in and started making
all the cuts changing the discipline
code and he completely demoralized the
British Police Service a few years later
as the cuts started to bite into resume
and I think it was May 2015 she went to
the police Federation conference and
they highlighted to her the concerns
that I'd been highlighting
ever since I broke from the ranks in the
police I would do hundreds of interviews
in my own time I took a two-year career
break to work primarily with victims
because after I broke from the ranks and
longed to protect the protectors the
public used to speak to me all over
London when I was off duty and they said
saw you on the television the other day
GMTV sky whatever it is you really care
about what's going on the streets you
give the police a voice that we haven't
got as victims so strangely enough I
actually launched the victims of crime
trust so I saw road to horses I spoke up
for the police and also there I spoke up
for the victims of crime
[Music]